[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Christian
Kämpfe zu Wasser und zu Land die
Ukrainer greifen russische Stellungen an
entscheidende Erfolge lassen aber auf
sich war
Griechen Italiener deutsch im Schweiße
vereint die Hitzewelle treibt die
Temperaturen vor allem in Südeuropa auf
über 40 Grad
und wenn die Nummer 42 der Weltrangliste
so richtig auftreten die Tschechien
Marketa wonder gewinnt in Wimbledon als
erste ungesetzte überhaupt
[Musik]
seit rund sechs Wochen versucht die
Ukraine mit einer gegen Offensive die
von Russland besetzten Gebiete zurück
zur erobern bislang mit geringen Gelände
gewinnen auch der ukrainische Präsident
dämpfte jetzt die Erwartungen man müsse
für jeden erkämpften Kilometer dankbar
sein beide Seiten sprechen von schweren
Gefechten Thomas Gonsior
Region Tressen ein Feuergefecht auf dem
Fluss der Krieg ist auch im knieprodelta
ukrainische Soldaten machen per Boot
Jagd auf russische Einheiten ein Schiff
zerstört fünf Besatzer getötet meldet
Kiew
Krieg zu Lande ein typischer Tag in der
Hölle kommentierte ukrainische Soldat
sein frontvideo
schussalben Schreie Stillstand es geht
kaum voran sagt nun auch der Präsident
klar sei dass die russischen Truppen im
Süden und Osten unseres Landes alles
ihnen Mögliche tun werden um unsere
Kämpfer aufzuhalten um jeden Kilometer
den unsere Truppen Vorankommen müssen
wir dankbar sein
Tiefstapelei als Taktik Tatsache ist die
gegen Offensive stockt die ukrainische
Armee sagt sie sei diese Woche im Süden
1,7 km vorgestoßen Ziel Richtung
militopol weiterzukommen bis zur Stadt
sind aber noch gut 70 km Problem dabei
immer noch der Nachschub aus den USA ist
nun solche Munition in der Ukraine
angekommen international geächtete
Streubomben zugesagt hat Kiew kein
Angriff auf Städte auf Zivilisten
auch ein Fronteinsatz kaum denkbar so
Experten nicht explodierte Sprengsätze
würden das eigene vorrücken verhindern
die Ukraine wird versuchen logistische
Einrichtungen zu Treffen
versorgungsstraßen zu Treffen
gefechtstände zu Treffen und auf diese
Art und Weise die Kampfkraft der
russischen Seite zu schwächen doch noch
reicht diese Kampfkraft offenbar allemal
für die russische Gegenwehr für
russische Attacken zu Lande und in der
Luft
weil man dem Feind keinen Rückschluss
auf die eigene Personalstärke geben will
nennt die Ukraine weiterhin keine Zahlen
zu getöteten oder verletzten Soldaten es
durften zehntausende sein mit
gravierenden Verletzungen viele haben
durch Minen oder Explosionen Beine oder
Arme verloren wir versucht wird Ihnen zu
helfen zeigt daran Hassan
keine Grenzen der Name des Kiefer
Rehabilitationszentrums gibt die
Richtung vor
Ruslan ist im März auf eine russische
Mine gedrehten jetzt kämpft er sich in
ein Leben mit Prothese
körperlich kam ich klar auf der
psychologischen Seite da versuchte ich
die ganze Zeit über positiv zu bleiben
nach der Explosion sah ich dass ich kein
Bein mehr habe es ist kein Grund darüber
in Panik zu geraten so versuchte ich
positiv zu bleiben mit Humor Stück für
Stück
Kampfgeist ist das eine eine passende
Prothese die andere Grundlage für den
Behandlungserfolg die Prothesen werden
in Handarbeit direkt in der Werkstatt
des Zentrums gefertigt individuell
abgestimmt auf die Form des Stumpfes
sehr oft helfen uns Prothesen den
Phantomschmerz zu bekämpfen wenn die
Spiegeltherapie oder andere Behandlungen
nicht wirken dann hilft es wenn die
Patienten sehen dass sie eine Prothese
haben sie verstehen es und der
Phantomschmerzen nimmt ab
70% der Patienten sind inzwischen
Soldaten und es werden mehr das Zentrum
arbeitet an der Kapazitätsgrenze zu dem
fehlenden Fachkräfte ausgebildete
prothesenbauer viele von ihnen sind
mittlerweile selbst im Krieg
nach Deutschland in die Diskussion um
eine mögliche Abschaffung des
Ehegattensplittings hat sich
Finanzminister Lindner eingeschaltet auf
Twitter schreibt der ich schließe das
auszufuhr hatte Lindner in einem
Interview gesagt eine Abschaffung sei
weder in der Koalition verabredet noch
für Steuerzahlerinnen und Zahler fair
das Ehegattensplitting bringt
Steuerersparnisse für Paare mit
unterschiedlich hohen Einkommen
ein wichtiges Ziel der Klimapolitik ist
der Umstieg auf Elektroautos aber es
geht nur in kleinen Schritten voran im
vergangenen Jahr stieg der Anteil neu
zugelassener E-Autos von 13,5% im ersten
auf
21,4% im zweiten Halbjahr seit Januar
sind die Kaufprämien niedriger jetzt
sind 15,8 Prozent der Neuwagen reine
Autos es sind aber nicht nur die
geringeren Prämien die den Umstieg auf
Elektro erschweren Christina igelseder
das E-Auto ein Hingucker aber schauen
nicht kaufen die Kunden entscheiden sich
am Ende Klimakrise hin und daher noch
immer meist für den Verbrenner
immer noch ein Vorteil ist natürlich die
Reichweite obwohl das manchmal gar nicht
mehr so stimmt wir haben auch eher Autos
mit mehrere Reichweite und ja von daher
ist das auch ganz viele
Einstellungssache für das angepeilte
Ziel 15 Millionen E-Autos auf deutschen
Straßen bis 2030 heißt es mehr Gas geben
denn die Verkaufszahlen liegen deutlich
unter den Erwartungen
Gründe sind sicher der singende
Umweltbonus das gibt einfach etwas
weniger Förderung vom Staat und
gleichzeitig hatten wir im letzten Jahr
relativ hohe Strompreise die sich ja
auch zu einer gewissen Verunsicherung
bei den Kunden beigetragen haben als
Folge der Absatzkrise drosseln Autobauer
wie Volkswagen bereits die Produktion im
Werk in Enden für mehr als eine
Milliarde Euro auf E-Mobilität
umgerüstet ist die Nachtschicht
gestrichen die Werksferien verlängert
auch die Lade Infrastruktur wurden mit
entscheidend für das gebremste Kunden
Interesse zwar ist die Zahl der
öffentlichen Säulen deutlich gestiegen
Schnellladen aber geht nur an jeder
sechsten die mit Teile etwa 90.000
Ladepunkte sind außerdem ungleich
verteilt fehlend vor allem im Osten auch
die markenpalette bei E-Autos noch zu
klein günstige kleinwagen sind
Mangelware mit dem breiten Angebot was
es im kommenden Jahr geben wird 160
Modelle allein von den deutschen
Herstellern der wird für jede
VerbraucherInnen und jeden Verbraucher
etwas dabei sein noch aber sind E-Autos
für viele wohl zu teuer doch der
Preiskampf hat begonnen nach dem Tesla
die Listenpreise gesenkt hat werden die
anderen Hersteller nachziehen müssen
damit demnächst deutlich mehr Stromer
vom hofrollen
ein Signal für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland kommt von Siemens der
technikkonzern investiert hier eine
Milliarde Euro allein 500 Millionen
davon in Erlangen dort will Siemens nach
eigenen Angaben die industrielle
Produktion
revolutionieren mit dem sogenannten
metaverse einer Verbindung aus realer
und digitaler Welt Peter Aumeier hat
Details
nicht nur Menschen können künftig einen
digitalen Zwilling haben auch Maschinen
ganze Fabriken werden digital
nachgebildet eins zu eins in jedem
Detail verbunden über Plattformen in
industriellen Mieters weltweit arbeiten
Firmen an dieser Technik auch Siemens
mit einer milliardeninvestition will der
Konzern nun ins mietervers investieren
besonders am Standort erlangen
ich glaube dass wir in einer Zeit leben
in der wir die eine Transformation
erleben wie viele zuvor mit einem
Unterschied diese Transformation ist
deutlich schneller weil die
Digitalisierung bringt die
Innovationsgeschwindigkeit auch jetzt in
die Hardware in die Art und Weise wie
wir die reale Welt betrachten in
Echtzeit verbunden kann im industriellen
mietervers eine Maschine aus der Ferne
gewartet Prozesse im Detail optimiert
und komplexe Vorgänge simuliert werden
die Vorteile des industriellen
mietervers Produktionen steigern
ressourcenschonen und die Zusammenarbeit
verbessern
experten sprechen von einer komplett
veränderten Arbeitswelt einer weiteren
industriellen Revolution
das wird einen ähnlichen Einfluss haben
weil es eben so hands-on ist so direkt
in unseren Händen und nicht mehr nur am
Schreibtisch ähnlich wie das Internet
eine Revolution war die vieles was man
sich vorher anderweitig hat
herbeischaffen müssen plötzlich dann
ständig zu unserer Verfügung gestellt
hat die Auswirkungen auf die Arbeitswelt
sind dort nicht völlig überschaubar doch
den Lehrgebieten Arbeitsmarkt könnte
diese Technik sogar eine Entlastung
bringen das ist auch ein Hilfsmittel
gegen den Fachkräftemangel weil in
dieses metavers ist egal ob man jetzt in
Südafrika in Saudi Arabien oder in China
ist man kann sich eben einfach virtuell
an einen Tisch setzen das industrielle
Mieters kommt nicht irgendwann es hat
längst begonnen
nach wiederholter Gewalt in Freibädern
in Berlin gelten ab heute schärfere
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen der Eintritt ist
nur noch mit Ausweis möglich neben dem
Personalausweis können die Besucher auch
ihren Führerschein oder Schülerausweis
zeigen um überfüllte Bäder zu vermeiden
soll künftig auch ein früherer
einlassstock gelten außerdem soll das
Sicherheitspersonal aufgestockt werden
Flugreisende in Italien brauchten heute
gute Nerven das Bodenpersonal streikte
für acht Stunden und 1000 flügefielen
aus landesweit waren etwa 250.000
Menschen von dem Streik betroffen bei
mehreren Fluggesellschaften legten auch
die Piloten die Arbeit nieder ein Streik
mitten in der Hauptreisezeit
und dazu ist es sengend heiß im Süden
Europas in Italien gilt in mehreren
Städten eine Hitzewarnung der Alarmstufe
Rot auch in Rom und Griechenland
befindet sich auf dem Höhepunkt der
aktuellen Hitzewelle mit Höchstwerten
über 40°c
Schlange stehen für die Kultur an der
Akropolis in Athen sind auch bei dieser
Hitze Menschen dazu bereit seit gestern
ist die Städte von 12 bis 17 Uhr
geschlossen doch auch morgens ist es
schon über 30 Grad brennt die Sonne
unbarmherzig es ist heiß aber man muss
sich richtig anziehen und Wasser trinken
war um 7 Uhr aufzustehen weil wir nicht
erst mittags hoch wollten es war heiß
aber es war schön wir sind ja im Urlaub
es sollte so heiß sein
in der Stadt sind sonst belebte Plätze
leer Athen kennt sich inzwischen aus mit
solchen Tagen wo das Thermometer über 40
Grad geht man bleibt im klimatisierten
zu Hause in Restaurants sagt Sprühnebel
für Abkühlung
früher beobachteten wir eine Hitzewelle
jetzt sind es zwei oder drei im Sommer
außerdem sehen wir wie jetzt einen
Anstieg der Dauer also mehr Tage mit
sehr hohen Temperaturen
auch in Italien brütende Hitze auf
Sizilien aber auch in Rom soll in den
nächsten Tagen die 40 Grad Marke
überschritten werden für 16 Städte hat
Italiens Zivilschutz die Hitze
Alarmstufe Rot ausgerufen man fürchtet
Waldbrände
wir sind im Alarm Modus wir haben schon
die Freiwilligen Feuerwehren kontaktiert
damit die nach Feiern Ausschau halten
wer kann ist in Italien heute an den
Strand gefahren der beste Platz bei
diesen Temperaturen
auch in den bayerischen Alpen sind
Klimaveränderungen spürbar auch hier
wird es immer trockener das ist für
Tiere und Pflanzen im Gebirge bedrohlich
aber auch die Hüttenwirte sind in Sorge
weil bei ihnen das Wasser knapp wird
Claudia Vogelmann war für uns in den
Berchtesgadener Alpen
wer ist hierher geschafft hat hat
mindestens viereinhalb Stunden bergauf
gehen in den Knochen 10.000 Wanderer
übernachten von Mai bis Oktober auf dem
Watzmannhaus groß waschen ist nicht drin
vor wenigen Jahren wurde das Haus
renoviert auf Komfort wurde bewusst
verzichtet
so sind keine Duschen eingebaut worden
und das Wasser ist sehr stark gedrosselt
selbst in der Küche wird Wasser gespart
wo ist nur geht Käse Spatzen bitte die
wird in nicht an der Käse würde zu stark
an den Tellern kleben bleiben selbst
Spülwasser spart sie ein auch die
Übernachtungsgäste sollen zu wenig
Wasser wie möglich verbrauchen es sind
20 Liter pro Übernachtungsgast die wir
brauchen
der Durchschnitt im Tal von einem ganz
normalen Bewohner liegt bei 130 Liter es
wird eng mit dem Schmelz und Regenwasser
weiter oben am Berg fehlen große
Schneefelder zu wenig Niederschlag im
Winter lange Trockenperioden in diesem
Sommer wenn man so die Prognosen der
Forscher glauben darf dann wird es dazu
führen dass in die nächsten 15 20 Jahren
doch einige Alpen schließen müssen das
was mein Haus soll auf jeden Fall
bleiben nun fordern wir Alpinisten eine
Wasserleitung aus dem Tal profitieren
könnten sie von einem möglichen
Anschluss der Kühe und allem weiter
unten am Berg einen Trainingszentrum der
Bundespolizei das Problem die Leitungen
würden dann mitten durch den
Nationalpark über den blankenfels nach
oben führen bei diesem Plan schlägt der
Bund Naturschutz Alarm
es handelt sich um die Kernzone des
einzigen alpen-nationalparks und es
müssen
naturschutzfachlich sehr hochwertige
Flächen durchschnitten werden und das
lehnen wir ab die Pläne die Schutzhütte
an die Wasserversorgung im Tal
anzuschließen sind umstritten am Ende
werden wohl die Gerichte entscheiden ob
das Watzmannhaus Wasser aus dem Tal
bekommt oder nicht
in Südkorea sind bei heftigen Unwettern
mindestens 26 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen 14 werden vermisst
tagelanger starker Regen hat zu
Überflutungen und Erdrutschen geführt
mehr als 6000 Menschen wurden
aufgefordert ihre Häuser zu verlassen in
tausenden Haushalten viel der Strom aus
und der koreanische Wetterdienst rechnet
mit weiteren schweren Regenfällen
das goldene Huhn so heißt ein
internationales Filmfest in der Ukraine
wegen des Kriegs haben es die
ukrainischen Organisatoren nach Erfurt
verlegt auch als danke an Deutschland
und Thüringen für die Unterstützung und
weil hier so viele Landsleute
aufgenommen werden zu sehen sind unter
anderem berührende Kurzfilme zeigt
Ulrike Nitschke
trotz Panzersperren und Ruinen Kinder in
der Ukraine wollen Kinder sein wie
überall auf der Welt das ist die
Botschaft von Borussia sie ist 12 Film
mit dem Handy und hat ihre Filme aus
Kiew nach Erfurt mitgebracht den Krieg
wird sie nicht los
und das brauchen sie Dusche Dusche
selbst wenn ich hier in Erfurt Flugzeuge
am Himmel höre reagiere ich total
verängstigt weil wenn ich in der Ukraine
diese Geräusche höre weiß ich irgendwo
fallen dann die Bomben
ein Vierteljahrhundert lang fand das
goldene Huhn jährlich in der Ukraine
statt nun hat der Verein ukrainische
Landsleute in Thüringen das Filmfest
nach Erfurt geholt im letzten Jahr war
das Festival in der Stadt mariopol
geplant aber dann kam der Krieg und wir
lassen das nicht sterben wir dürfen das
nicht machen wir lassen das Festival
hier weiterleben in diesem Jahr bewertet
eine Ukraine deutsche Jury unter der
Leitung von Valentin missli 26 Kurzfilme
über den Alltag im Krieg und fern der
Raketen und Drohnen Angriffe
unabhängig vom Krieg wollen die Künstler
in der Ukraine aktiv bleiben und aktiv
handeln nicht nur mit Filmen über Krieg
sondern auch über Kultur ganz gleich wie
die Situation ist die Kultur
muss erhalten bleiben
Valentin missli war kurz nach
Kriegsbeginn nach Thüringen geflüchtet
er arbeitet momentan an einem
Dokumentarfilm über Erfurt
marusa wird morgen direkt nach der
Preisverleihung wieder in ihre
Heimatstadt Kiel zurückkehren
jetzt zum Sport toller Auftrag für die
deutsche Mannschaft bei den
Schwimmweltmeisterschaften in Japan
gleich zu Beginn gab's Gold Christin und
dazu noch die olympiaqualität die
glückliche Leonie Beck aus Würzburg dank
einer äußerst klugen Renneinteilung
entschied sie in Fukuoka den 10
km-wettbewerb der Frauen im Freiwasser
für sich und löste gleichzeitig das
Ticket für die Sommerspiele in Paris
die 26-Jährige hält sich immer in der
Spitzengruppe aber klug hier an Position
3 im Windschatten auf 7 km vor dem Ziel
dann ein erstes Loch zum großen Feld und
Leonie Beck zieht spät den schlußsport
an hat die besseren Reserven und siegt
schließlich knapp vor der Australien
Chelsea der sie 4,1 Sekunden nach 10 km
abnimmt in Zeit 2 Stunden 2 Minuten und
34 Sekunden Dritte wird Rebecca Grimes
USA Leonberg gleich am ersten Tag mit
der ersten goldenen für den deutschen
Schwimmverband
und in Paris musste paraarbeits-springer
Markus Rehm bei den Weltmeisterschaften
die ganze Nacht warten bis ein sechstes
Gold nacheinander offiziell bestätigt
wurde alles wie gewohnt Markus Rehm
überlegener Sieger zum sechsten Mal
Weltmeister zwischen zwei Konkurrenten
aus den USA just die US-Amerikaner
legten jedoch später Protest ein Rehm
soll nicht zulässige Spikes benutzt
haben seine 8 m 49 die nach ihr regulär
er regte Debatten hinter den Kulissen
heute morgen ziehen die USA den Protest
zurück die Spikes seien technisch alle
gleich behaupten Reim und seine Tränen
[Musik]
eine hartnäckige Verletzung am Fuß
zwingt den 34-Jährigen nun zu einer
längeren Pause vor dem olympia-
mit einer Überraschung endete das
frauenturnieren Wimbledon die Tschechien
Marketa wondere sogar gewann als erste
ungesetzter Tennisspielerin den
rasenklassiker
dieses wimbalkenmärchen rührt auch
Tennis Ikone Martina Navratilova denn
die favorisierte vorjahrsfinalistin
orange im Hintergrund schöpft nur im
zweiten Satz einmal kurz Hoffnung als
sie nach 040 noch zum eins zu eins
ausgleicht doch die Tunesierin auf die
ganz Afrika blickt kann ihre Nervosität
nicht verdrängen kassiert erneut zwei
Breaks parketta von drassover nach nur
einer Stunde 20 Minuten mit dem zweiten
Matchball zum 6:44 Uhr Jubel von
Schwester und Ehemann über den nach
schweren schlagernverletzung
überraschenden ganzer Erfolg
die 14 etappe der Tour de France und das
Spitzen Duell bleibt mega spannend
gemeinsam kommt dass du weniger pogaccia
über den letzten Berg Richtung Museen wo
der Spanier Carlos Rodrigues Tagesticker
wird dahinter die pogaccia vor Jonas
weniger der mit 10 Sekunden Vorsprung
weiter in gelb fährt ich habe es gesehen
echt spektakulär danke schön Christin
auch bei uns war es heute wieder
ziemlich heiß in Dresden kletterte das
Thermometer auf 37 Grad und das im
Schatten ähnliche Temperaturen gab es am
Breitenauer See in Baden-Württemberg der
Strand war hier fast leer gefegt die
Menschen verbrachten den Tag lieber im
kühleren Wasser
heute Nacht ziehen starke Gewitter über
den Süden Deutschlands morgen wird es
deutlich ruhiger bei angenehmeren
Temperaturen die Details hat gleich
Katja horneffer das heute journal mit
Marietta Slomka um Viertel vor elf ihnen
wünschen wir alles Gute einen schönen
Samstag noch und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend in Bayern stiegen heute die
Temperaturen bis 39 Grad am östlichen
Mittelmeer wird es noch heißer mit bis
zu 44 Grad wer jetzt hofft das
Mittelmeer brechter eine gewisse
Abkühlung sieht sich getäuscht die
Wassertemperaturen des südlichen
Mittelmeeres liegen bei 27 bis 29 Grad
und auch nachts wird sich wirklich
frisch Antalya hatte in der vergangenen
Nacht eine Tiefsttemperatur von 32 Grad
was Abkühlung bringt sind Wolken die
haben heute bei uns aus besten
heranbrachten Regen mit und später dann
auch Gewitter jetzt formieren sich neue
Gewitter über Frankreich und die werden
im Laufe der Nacht über
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern weiter nach
Nordosten ziehen das können zum Teil
Unwetter sein also Gewitter die mit
hagelplatz Regen und sturmhöhlen
verbunden sind auch im Norden gibt es
einige Schauer und Gewitter die fallen
allerdings nicht so heftig aus die
Temperaturen sinken auf 21 bis 13 Grad
und morgen geht's noch einige Gewitter
am alten Hand und kräftige Regenschauer
bei einem heftigen Südwestwind hier an
der Nordsee sonst wird es freundlich und
die Temperaturen steigen auf 21 bis 30
Grad mit einer Wetter drei Teilung geht
es dann bis zur Mitte der nächsten Woche
weiter und ich wünsche Ihnen jetzt ein
schönes Wochenende